bell n'a rien mais vous aimez il n'a
rien le pauvre on était alors je vous
explique l'histoire pour que les jets
cyril féraud en fait on a fait croire
avec l'aide de sa production que
j'allais venir sur le plateau de slam et
le piéger grimm et donc en fait il a cru
que c'était moi qui allais jouer
le seul hic c'est que c'était pas moi en
fait il est persuadé que le gars qui
joue c'est moi mais c'est pas moi le
gars s'appelle laaziz regarder cela on a
plaisir et le terrain
[Musique]
je vais
et c'est parti pour le slam on applaudit
la reprise qui est à vos côtés bonjour à
vous qu'est ce que vous faites dans la
vie je suis professeur de zumba besoin
la vraie question de zumba oui prof de
zumba à cergy pontoise cergy pontoise et
j'avais tout le monde à venir au lard be
dance tout le monde tout le monde en une
démo alors de zumba quand vous voulez
j'ai jamais fait de cours de zumba
voulais m'en faire un si vous êtes prêts
à laisser je suis toujours pas élargie
voilà comment on fait je suis alors vous
me suivez
when you tube fonctionnel tout est bon
pour l'avenir il va falloir payer
en fait là vous avez compris c'est à
dire qu'il veut pas nous montrer comment
on fait pour qu'on aille dans le club et
qu'on paye c'est comme ça que ça de la
vitesse je vous promets les résultats
sont incroyables vous avez un air des
nuages troupe de cyril hanouna n'entre
pas soit pas le public
un petit air tout le monde est prêt on y
va et très bonne chance à tous les trois
questions de culture générale pour
démarrer on cherche des lettres
attention quelle lettre reçue
immédiatement sa voisine l'alphabet s
non c'est pas le smb cifs à véronique
l'été c'est le tc saint-louis sermon
familier pour dévier la nourriture la
boustifaille l'artiste vous êtes super
stressé j'arrive chez moi pourtant je
vous promet gérard et devenir la risée
vous avez vous êtes cyril hanouna c'est
pas possible on me dit ça mais je trouve
qu'il ya un maire je sais pas moi j'y
peux rien moi d'abord vous ouvrirez il
ya pire comme ça que je suis moche et ça
va plus vite
on trouvait moche selena en continu
question de vocabulaire
quelle lettre manque deux fois pour
avoir de l'appétit de l'appétit des fous
alors oui il est dingue
allez si arlette wallonie et le mais
c'est le oui mais non mais vous avez
passé chez arlette l'arize temps claude
thierry labelle aziz sait pas vous mais
pas cela mais maintenant si non mais
c'est pas possible c'est cyril hanouna
je vous ai reconnu cela mais alors vous
avez cela mais vous savez quand vous
cela mais vous devez compléter la grille
sans les définitions nudité elle habille
envers la nudité toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas possible
l'arize l'arize elle a très peur je
visais en fait je suis quasi persuadé
que vous êtes cyril hanouna mais j'ai
juste un truc qui m'énerve c'est qu'ils
aient pas comme ça normalement ça vous
avez une période
attendez il faut que je vous ouvre la
chemise
non on fait une émission de télévision
là on fait quoi la remise il faut que je
vous ouvre les chemises belle à rien
mais vous aimez ya rien le pauvre non
non non non non je ne veux rien voir moi
je suis désolé l'art 6 serral est elle
vaut pas que je gagne maintenant arlette
à la super meat boy que dis-je était
grande chez mega relais des rêves de
prendre des cours de zumba la regarde et
nous l'a dit la dernière fois les venez
jechoux allez venez venez
j'ai cru que c'était une perruque blonde
ses traits comme ça jamais montre plus
comme ça tout va bien savoir comment
faire un câlin oui c'est bien je peux
aller au ddc cru que c'était une
perruque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai super mal
j'étais super mal cette fois mentionné
la production slam